Lauren Fred Armisen pointed out a thing
that when Lauren has to name drop which
he does a lot because he knows like he
knows all of his friends are super
famous Super Famous he always kind of
rubs his eyes like this like he's really
put out by the amount of famous people
you know and uh
and uh so we would do a bit uh John
Solomon and some of the writer with Norm
of Lauren uh name-dropping serial
killers
he goes to restaurants to hang out and
with famous people and famous serial
killers join him yeah yeah so like one
would be like I went to Kansas City
um
with Alec and Marcy uh to try to
get BTK killer off death row
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they said Here Comes BTK I go you know
his name is Dennis
he's a human being